I think that the struggle is a bit of an
honor and I think if you want to know
what the key to happiness is it's
struggle if you want to know what the
key to wealth is it's struggle if you
want to know what the the key to making
a lot of money is it's struggle and the
more that you can realize that iron
actually does sharpen iron and the more
sort of difficult things you can
champion and do the more likely you are
to have a successful life
um I I think it's a life hack it's a
secret that these days we don't want to
hear now everybody wants you know I want
to do the least and make the most I want
to hire the least amount of people and
have the biggest company I'm a solo
entrepreneur that will never employ
anybody that makes millions on the
internet you can do it too without any
work in four hours a week like that's
the thing that we've said we want and
then I think about it for a second I
stand back and I'm like is that really
what we want like what happened to
building Empires what happened to
leaving legacies what are you going to
do in the other 52 hours of your week
and so I don't think you have to
struggle forever but I think periods of
struggle make the periods of relaxation
really poignant and with one without the
other is like a day without a night
nobody wants to live in a complete
pleasure and happiness always because it
diminishes and so I do think you need it
I mean what do you think because you
went through worse sleep deprivation in
medical school than I did yeah this is
the thing that I'm not sure about like
um
I've been looking a lot into this in the
process of writing my book
um where
you know there's that quote from
Muhammad Ali which is
um you know I thought about quitting but
I said you know don't quit suffer now
and live the rest of your life as a
champion and this whole thing of like I
suffered for 10 years and then it was
worth it at the end of it because I held
up a trophy kind of vibe yeah and that
has never really sit right with me
because
if you know when when I was when I was
when I was talking to to Alexi he's he
said something which I I think about
quite a lot which is that
you know when I when I was when I was 20
I would have given everything to be a
millionaire and when I was a millionaire
I would have given everything to be 20
again
and so usually I feel like these periods
of struggle When We're Young in
particular like
like if we look at
the regrets of the dying on the on the
deathbed basically everyone says I wish
I hadn't worked so hard and I think for
people who are very driven
there is a kind of a default tendency to
over invest in work and under invest in
relationships and health and I know a
few people for whom that has screwed
them up because they've gotten to their
let's say mid-30s 40s whatever they've
chased the corporate ladder of success
in entrepreneurship or whatever they
might think that thing might be their
whole life and then they look around and
they're like oh crap all my friends are
married with kids and I and I've just
been chasing chasing the green dollars
yeah and I will I wonder if
like the way I've always tried to
approach it is you know when I was going
through med school building YouTube
channel working as a doctor it was
always around how can I make this
process enjoyable and energizing for
myself so that it doesn't feel as if I
am struggling or grinding and stuff yeah
and maybe that's that kind of millennial
like wanting to have their cake and eat
a two kind of situation but when you
said
when you said struggle is happiness
that's where I was like oh I'm not sure
I will I would venture that balance is
happiness and
there are periods of struggle certainly
because growth comes from struggle
almost certainly but then there's the
other side of it which is
happiness comes from you know having
friends to hang out with and taking care
of your health and all those things as
well so yeah yeah I've yeah what do you
what do you think well I think you're
right I think it's important not to
assume that struggle can only be in work
so I think you're right about that we
talk about something called a third
degree human basically like a third
degree black belt and so we have a
triadic contrarian thinking that's
civilized the Mind makes Savage the body
build the bank account
so the idea is the Civilized the Mind
makes Savage the body as an ancient
Chinese proverb translated but basically
that yeah you want to how do you
civilize the mind you read incredible
things right you have interesting
conversations you question things you
struggle with that voice inside of your
head that's always telling you negative
perceptions right and you try to not
tame the beast but understand it and
that's like one type of struggle right
and then you have make Savage the body
which is a different type of struggle
it's like the struggle to
um eat well you know the the J like I
don't know like do you find Joy I find a
lot of joy in an incredibly hard workout
like a yoga session where you're just
dripping sweat but the music's
incredibly difficult and I so maybe
there are different types of humans too
but I find that when I kind of take it
to the edge that there's this there's
Beauty in it there's like Beauty in
how far can you push your body you know
how far can you push your mind how much
can you create yeah and then maybe that
is where happiness kind of strides the
bigger issue I think I see today is that
so many people
so many people seem like they don't have
a purpose anymore and like We're a
nation of people who their deathbed they
say that because they chose a job
because of outside memetic reasons that
they stuck with for 10 or 20 or 30 or 40
years or they looked for Fast Cash and
fast rewards and never found it as
opposed to
I don't know about you but I get so lost
in the moments where I'm doing the thing
I should be doing you know when I'm
writing really deeply when I'm thinking
really deeply when I'm having an
engaging conversation but I'm struck
like even right now I'm like I'm
struggling to think of how do I say this
exactly but there's like I'm finding it
very interesting you know what would not
be interesting us talking about the
weather which would be super easy us
watching a Mindless TV show that is so
uninteresting to me so maybe we need a
better definition of struggle yeah yeah
I think that's it because yeah as you
were describing that
um the whole you know shopping the mind
the body thing
I think
it's a one one example I can think of is
you know during lockdown I got a PS5 I
started to play Horizon zero Dawn and I
switched to very hard difficulty it
wasn't quite Ultra hard which is just a
bit torturous but very hard was like a
good sweet spot yeah where my housemate
would see me just like trying to clear
the same bandicamp for about three hours
because it was on very hard difficulty
and you had to get the right like
headshot to make sure that they're new
to see you and all this kind of stuff
and at the end of it would be like oh
yes I'm glad I spent the last three
hours on very hard difficulty I could
have breezed through it in five seconds
on story mode difficulty but like what
what would be the point of that like
exactly that there is joy to be found in
the challenge itself
but at the same time if
that's I think where the where where I
think about this idea of balance
you know that's three hours from like I
don't know eight to eleven PM while it's
locked down but you know if that was
four hours five hours six hours seven
hours and the rest of my life is
suffering now I might be struggling with
very hard difficulty in our Horizon zero
Dawn or even Ultra hard but I'm unlikely
to be particularly happy because the
rest of life is not quite in Balance
totally and so I kind of think of it as
these moments of moments of challenge
you know in the in the in the book we've
got a chapter around play like if you
can find a way to approach your work in
the spirit of play which is often with a
sense of wonder and curiosity but a
decent sprinkle of challenge as well
yeah that's what makes it fun and that's
kind of been my Approach for well since
Medical School how do I take this
Challenge and find a way to make it fun
or if I'm doing something really boring
how do I apply a challenge to it to make
it more fun than it currently is so yeah
I totally agree I mean I think I I think
we forget sometimes that most humans if
you go to ask it's one of my favorite
games I do it a lot to Uber drivers like
I'll say something like
you know what was your day like today
like what did you I just want to see a
different perspective so here in London
I think that's interesting like how many
hours you've been driving what's going
on and then I like to ask them when was
the last time that you did something so
hard you could barely stand it and the
reason I like to ask that is because
every time I ask myself that I realize
oh shoot it's been a little bit hard
longer than I anticipate you know when
was the last time you stayed up all
night working on something because you
couldn't help but do it right and when
you ask yourself that question then it
makes you push yourself slightly to find
those things and in moments where I
haven't done that in six months let's
say I realize ugh I have been grinding
I've not been struggling I've just been
sort of on a low level grind which I
think is soul killing and oftentimes
they'll tell me something really
interesting like I just had a baby you
know three months ago and I I never
thought I could survive in that moment
what was happening and that was that was
really cool there's actually this great
book called The Men the mission and me
it's about a Green Beret so special
forces in the U.S and and he has a line
in there that basically says there is
nothing more motivating than a mission
you're unsure you can solve and uh I
think I think that's why we're put here
as humans hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day bye